here's another thing folks um I watched
the Irishman does anyone in this
business die does anyone walk the [ __ ]
away when they need can you just get up
and walk away from the table I know
they're all legends I know they've done
a million things but that movie sucks it
is boring and it sucks and I love
everybody out on social media like
defending its honor it's all these
people that are in love with the past
and they can't let it [ __ ] go and
it's never the people that live through
it it's never the people who were like
actually there it's like [ __ ] people
that I like idolize mobsters even though
they work at Geico and they have no
[ __ ] idea and they think in their in
their lured imaginations they run some
card game with Jimmy and Nicki and these
people just [ __ ] they love the past
and you're like I hate all the new
movies I'm not gonna I don't like them
they're all about babies all these do
movies are about babies they're about
Jenna I like when men were men you know
and then people used to smoke and smack
women in the face you know it's such a
[ __ ] first of all the the first scene
of the movie they're all CGI because
they're all the so these so these are
all older actors like Pesci and De Niro
and they CGI them to make them look
younger
so you it's just a bunch of CGI corpses
for the first thing in the movie I know
so many talented people that can't
afford water and and it's just the same
people over and over again it's like you
couldn't make a mob move you couldn't
make this movement but the whole thing
is it's just a [ __ ] money grab
they're like well it's Scorsese we're
gonna make it with Keitel and De Niro
and Pacino and Pesci and they're all old
and it's like it's just not good it's
drawn-out it's long and and people are
just [ __ ] you know and now people are
getting really testy about it like
people are adopting the Irishman as like
you know this they're like it's a
masterpiece
these are legends and oh you don't like
it cuz what it's so you don't like it
cuz you're a [ __ ] were you cat videos
you don't like the Irish
it's a guy's it we saw it already it was
called Goodfellas it was better it was
shorter there's a movie called Hoffa
right we saw that we did it we've done
with these kind of movies where it's
like a narrator is explaining like hey
this is tall you know the first time I
met Tony I was in to speak it's and good
for Sebastian and Jim Norton guys that I
think are amazing they're in it great
but it's just like let's move the [ __ ]
on
let's stop and I see these people on
social media that are really that are
really loving the movie and it's you
know it's not like it's people that like
think that if they were alive in that
time they'd be like part of the Rat Pack
and it's like no you wouldn't be part of
the Rat Pack you'd be a guy who one of
these guys would embarrass and like hit
in the back of the head with a butt of a
gun
so this fantasy land you live in where
you think you're like you know you think
you're Dean Martin it's not the case
it's a boring [ __ ] movie and the
people that like it can't can't
understand or appreciate that we've
moved the [ __ ] on we've moved on from
this enough already
I like it cause it's towards the whole
world and you see the way that the
people used to be into all their legends
you know smoking jackets and Cadillacs
shut the [ __ ] up go back to your cubicle
at Geico enough you [ __ ] clown you
think you're some [ __ ] Vegas mobster
so [ __ ] yeah you'll could not the
guys you know could look to god she's
such a Long Island [ __ ] Jersey movie
a bunch of [ __ ] people that think
they're connected to the Mafia because
they're dumb uncle went to jail once cuz
he was used as a [ __ ] patsy and they
think there's somehow in the mob and
they all [ __ ] have you know
Goodfellas and Scarface posters on their
room on their walls and you're 38 years
old
they live with their mother and they
waited for her to fall down the stairs
so they can inherit a [ __ ] house and
they think they're like Jimmy Hoffa they
think they're like a real Street guy you
know all the Irishman is good it's great
movie you know you're my cousin you're
all
is one of those movies were like
everybody will tell their like I grew up
in a town with legit mafia people and
that and it yet informed that the way I
grew up to an extent but it's like I
don't romanticize any of that horseshit
it's cool the food was good but it's
like why can't we stop you cut it out
please
you're a [ __ ] grown up enough with
the plate I'm like you [ __ ] have any
clue the Irishman
seven hours I showered in the middle of
it I didn't even stop it I showered I
did launch ready it was in and out of
the room it's so long it's so long and
then they have this scene where it's not
a scene but it's like the after thing
with Scorsese and they're all talking
about like making the movie and stuff
like that
it's like Scorsese how about stepping
out of your [ __ ] comfort zone make a
movie about about black trans women
why don't you impress me stop making
movies about these [ __ ] goons we get
it how about you show that you got a
little [ __ ] range make him make a
movie about babies who grow up to be
gangsters I mean enough already I did
Denis who I've talked about on the show
life in the big city loved these movies
he loved those and I get it cuz they had
a place and he grew up and he knew the
guys and he knew the plays he knew it he
knew Henry Hill he knew those guys they
lived in a town that I grew up but the
people that are really identifying with
the Irishman are not people that had any
[ __ ] clue what was going on during
that time at all they did nothing no
[ __ ] idea
they just romanticize it because they
think that if they had lived then boy
would have been real real real different
you know it would have been really
[ __ ] running the show they'd be
really running the table you know little
insane I just see all these people oh oh
yeah all these people don't like the
Irish yeah it's an objectively bad movie
it's boring it's objectively bad have
you seen it yeah yeah
such a waste for people like a pest she
came out of retirement it's like no he
should have stayed in it he did the
right thing
go go back to retirement and let
somebody else have a shot let someone
have a chance let somebody else please
have a chance please we don't need this
what are we gonna be doing we're gonna
are we gonna just animate their dead
bodies is that gonna be the next movie
that we make when they when they're
literally dead III don't understand
they're all on death's door they've had
great lives and great careers they've
done amazing things let them be nobody
needs this but it is it's a big
moneymaker because it's the boomers love
it mm-hmm boomers love it
so whatever that's my piece on the
Irishman I know that people give me flak
for that I know people get angry it did
well would it make 140 mill well that's
the budget that's the budget it was a
hundred forty million dollars Jesus that
was all spent a colostomy bags for the
talent so they could piss themselves and
they don't have to stop filming you know
enough already not enough these [ __ ]
people I you know it's you go on social
media it's the same people
it's like Susie Benedetto's like I love
the Irishman it's such a great that's
when things made sense yeah did they did
they how about you gonna make a lasagna
you neanderthal I bet you go it does it
does make sense I'd like those yeah you
that time when women were not on
Facebook they were making ravioli so go
back to that how about you follow the
example of the Irishman and shut the
[ __ ] up and get back in the kitchen if
you like that time so much how about you
follow the rules and stop opining about
culture we don't need it Maryann we
don't need it don't make a meatloaf I
just you know it
people are like nostalgic for periods of
time that they didn't even [ __ ] live
through this 1950s horseshit where
everything was so good but we were you
know siccing dogs on black kids trying
to go to school you know like well what
did I get it modernity sucks it has its
problems but let's stop jerking off the
past every [ __ ] it's the sign of a
dead society that were jerking the past
off all the time and can someone show up
to the new set of Mad About You with a
gun and tell Paul Reiser and Helen Hunt
that have enough [ __ ] money that
nobody Marie's dead the dog's dead
nobody needs that [ __ ] show again that
wasn't good when it was on the air mad
about you how empty are people's lives
that they need this [ __ ] well what's
Frasier Crane been doing what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you get a life these
people who is this for Disney Plus what
are you doing watching The Little
Mermaid you're a 38 year old man stop
reading Harry Potter in public you're an
adult enough I mean this this Disney
Plus lunacy if you have kids and you
want to show them these things I get it
but you know the amount of you know
Jared Logan had a great point he's like
Disney is the first culture you're
exposed to it's not supposed to be the
last you're not supposed to go well I'm
just gonna stay here all those movies I
saw when I was three that's where I'll
stay I just want to watch the Lion King
on loop when I was on the tour bus I had
these couple that came on my tour bus
they hated New York City they really
didn't like it New York's not for
everyone but you know this woman and her
husband they hated New York City they
were to you know blobs and they came in
and they sat down and they had disney
shirts on and they go you know we were
gonna take a Disney cruise we take a
Disney cruise every year but this time
we decided to go to New York and they go
we just we didn't really like it we
didn't enjoy it they go the one thing we
did enjoy was the Lion King Mego we saw
the Lion King play and that was nice we
don't like anything else we
we just don't like it we don't you know
and I'm like whoa they go we just want
to go to Disney World and I said well
why do you like Disney World they go
well it's just the best place on earth
you don't have any responsibilities I'm
like but that's not life right I mean I
said to them I go well that's not life
right I mean that's for children
children have no responsibilities
because they're children
but you're adults right so no matter
where you are you have some
responsibilities right and they're like
well no you know Disney World you're
just totally you know you have no
responsibilities just it's the best play
center and like you could say you could
tell that like every question I asked
was making them angrier because I was
like I was it was an assault to them
because they were very happy in their
living coma and they just wanted they
were just like no I just want to be
taking pictures with Mickey on the
Disney cruise you know you could tell
this was a couple that like held hands
that had never seen each other's
genitals and you know had probably you
know it's sick it's a sickness this is a
disease Disney is a disease it's enough
and they suck these movies don't hold up
I tried to watch lady in the [ __ ] the
other day it sucks and it used to be
great
but you know why was a kid it doesn't
really hold on I do like the Siamese cat
scene that is good still because I like
them and I like the way that they kind
of you know that I like um that holds up
certain films do hold up Song of the
South holds up that is a really that's a
joke that's a joke everyone don't get
excited
put the torch down put the torch down
put the citronella candle out don't get
it too excited just kidding it's comedy
[Music]